John we have a question let's come in
from Brad Hodges his twitter handle is
at icarly dried asks are there any major
differences between the structure of a
drama and the arranged structure a
reality show their huge differences and
they're based almost totally on the type
of genre that that show might be working
in so for example in the drama area we
have all of the major genres that we
have in film for example detective crime
we have soap opera we have fantasy
horror science fiction etc now these
genres determine the primary beats of
how that particular show plays out with
a reality show there are John Rosaire as
well so for example we might have a game
based reality show like The Bachelor or
survivor versus a show like any of the
housewife shows that are based on a
setting of a pseudo family and watching
them fight as much as possible so it
again depends on how that show is
constructed is to help with the drama
beats are and how they play out the one
thing that relates them all together
though is that they're all based on
hitting 27 major story structure steps
because any television show like any
movie a novel short story play the story
what makes the story work is does that
story hit those seven major structure
steps because that's the DNA of your
story and so that is the most important
element in terms of whether that is a
good story or not
you